ja ich finde sie haben das richtige
Weise angesprochen wenn ich mir die
Reaktionen aus der Regierungskoalition
anschaue der eine FDP Abgeordnete
spricht von einer Atombombe für unser
Land der andere von einem
heizungsverbotsgesetz dann zeigt es doch
im Grunde genommen schon wie
handwerklich schlecht die
Bundesregierung davor geht und wenn ich
mir das Gebäude Energiegesetz anschaue
dann ist es eben ein Gesetz das zu
tiefsten grünen Geist der bevormundungs
der Verbotspolitik atmet man muss sich
das einmal vorstellen den Menschen wird
vorgeschrieben wie sie zu heizen haben
und zwar nicht in einiger Zeit sondern
ab dem ersten Januar 2004 und 20 und
wenn Sie sich das mal anschauen die FDP
hat davon gesprochen das sei jetzt
technologieoffen das ist nicht
technologieoffen ja das hoffen Sie
vielleicht das was da auf dem Tisch
liegt verbietet sogar Biomasse also
Pellets Heizungen beispielsweise
und es führt egal welchen Weg sie nehmen
am Ende immer zur Wärmepumpe weil ganz
offensichtlich im
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums Strom
Fetischisten sitzen die glauben dass
alles durch Strom und damit durch das
Instrument der Wärmepumpe geregelt
werden kann jetzt muss man einfach sehen
mal ganz abgesehen davon dass wir in
Deutschland wahrscheinlich gar nicht die
Anlagen haben die 700.000 Wärmepumpen
pro Jahr produzieren könnten wir haben
mit Sicherheit nicht die Zehntausende
von zusätzlichen heizungsmonteuren und
Installateuren die das dann auch
umsetzen könnten sondern in ganz vielen
Fällen wird es nicht nur abartig teuer
sein sondern es wird schlicht
physikalisch unmöglich sein eine
Wärmepumpe in einem Altbau funktioniert
nicht sondern sie brauchen dann
umfassende renovierungs- und
Sanierungsarbeiten und dann reden wir
über Beträge von mehreren 10.000 €. das
wird dazu führen dass Häuser die aus den
70er aus der 80er Jahren starben über
Nacht an Wert massiv verlieren werden
das was die Bundesregierung hier macht
ist im Grunde genommen Vernichtung von
volkswirtschaftlichem Vermögen privaten
Vermögen öffentlichem Vermögen und jetzt
könnte man ja sagen oder es wird immer
noch gesagt ja wir werden das
entsprechend fördern also erstens mal
ist es immer noch Geld der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und zweitens wenn man ein
solches Gesetz auf den Weg bringt und
trotzdem nicht sagen kann wie Förderung
aussieht dann passt eben einfach das
eine nicht zu dem anderen das ist
Verbotspolitik wir haben eigentlich in
anderen Weg beschritten nämlich indem
wir CO2 bepreisen und damit einen
marktwirtschaftlichen Weg finden die
Menschen dazu zu bringen ihr Verhalten
so zu verändern dass weniger CO2
ausgeschlossen
Belastungsprobe werden was glauben Sie
wie gefährlich wird das wirklich für die
Ampel
ich glaube dass das sehr gefährlich wird
wir erleben das in den öffentlichen
Diskussionen ich erlebe das auch in
vielen Zwiegesprächen weil das eine
Politik ist die Angst auslöst ganz
normale Menschen die Mitte unserer
Gesellschaft deren wesentliches Vermögen
im selbstgenutzten Wohneigentum steckt
die haben das Gefühl der Staat kommt
jetzt und nimmt mir mein Haus weg ich
werde es nicht mehr halten können es
gibt im übrigen auch viele Punkte die
sind verfassungswidrig oder jedenfalls
höchst fragwürdig wenn sie etwa sehen
dass solche Regelungen für 80-Jährige
nicht gelten sollten aber für 79-Jährige
sehr wohl dann ist doch klar dass das
dass das mindestens fragt würde ist und
ein zweiter Punkt den ich ansprechen
möchte man verunsichert die Leute man
verängstigt die Leute man nimmt sie
nicht mit auf diesem Weg das ist glaube
ich das entscheidende Problem sprechen
Sie mal mit den entsprechenden
Unternehmen die sagen Ihnen sie haben
noch nie so viele Öl und Gasheizungen
wie derzeit verkauft das Ding ist schon
ein bisschen nach einer Wahlkampfrede
macht sich die CDU jetzt schon bereit
wenn die Ampel an diesem Thema
zerbrechen sollte dann schon mal sich in
den Stuhl zu setzen eine gute Opposition
hat natürlich immer eigene Ideen und
jederzeit bereit Verantwortung für das
Land zu übernehmen das ist keine Frage
das heißt aber würde dieses Gesetz nicht
kommen nein mit der CDU würde dieses
Gesetz ganz sicher nicht kommen also ich
stimme erstmal alles zu alles richtig
was ich gesagt haben jetzt kommt es aber
das aber ist die Frau Merkel hat damit
angefangen und wenn die CDU glaubwürdig
diese Position vertreten will die sich
eben vertreten haben dann muss man auch
mal selbstkritisch das Aufarbeiten ja
Frau Merkel hat angefangen hat die
Atomkraftwerke abgestellt eine riesen
Fehler auch mit meiner Partei ich sag
wir müssen auch selbstkritisch sein ja
freaking ist verboten in Deutschland ja
was dafür dass wir jetzt Tracking Gas
aus den USA importieren es wurde
angefangen moderne Kohlekraftwerke
abzustellen nicht von rot grün oder von
der Ampel ja sondern von der CDU
Regierung ja und das heißt ich finde das
alles toll was ich sagen aber können sie
nicht auch einfach mal sagen ja hier ist
viel in der Merkels halt falsch gelaufen
und wir als CDU machen jetzt da
Neuanfang da würde ich immer noch nicht
ich bin eine Halbzeit 27 Jahre FDP also
ich werde immer noch nicht beitreten
aber vielleicht würde ich dann mal doch
das ein bisschen glaubwürdiger finden in
dem Moment also überall wo gearbeitet
wird werden auch Fehler gemacht aber
fairerweise muss man natürlich jede
Entscheidung auch in die jeweilige Zeit
stellen und vor dem Hintergrund wir
haben 2011 da haben sie vollkommen Recht
die Entscheidung getroffen aus der
friedlichen Nutzung der Kernenergie
auszuscheiden wir sind aber jetzt in der
Situation wo wir mit zwei Dingen
konfrontiert sind zum einen der
energieversorgungsunsicherheit etwas was
sich ein Industrieland wie Deutschland
nicht leisten kann und zum zweiten geht
es natürlich auch um Preise also die
Wirtschaftsweise Veronika Grimm die hat
ja ausgerechnet dass durch den Ausstieg
aus der Kernenergie die Preise beim
Strom etwa um 12% steigen werden und das
ist natürlich ein Argument in einem Land
in dem wir die höchsten Strom und
Energiepreise der Welt haben
ich bin davon überzeugt dass die
Kernenergie so wie wir sie zuletzt
betrieben haben sicherlich keine
Energieform der Zukunft ist aber was zum
Beispiel auch auffällig ist wenn Sie
sich jetzt die aktuelle Situation
anschauen da werden ja nicht mal mehr
rückbaubeschlüsse abgearbeitet und
abgewartet sondern da wird ja in einer
Form der Bilderstürmerei des Fanatismus
ist werden jetzt im Grunde genommen wird
versucht eine Unumkehrbarkeit zu
erreichen und insbesondere eines
vielleicht noch zuletzt ich glaube
insbesondere was die Forschungsförderung
anbelangt müssen wir uns für die Zukunft
alles offen halten da geht zum
Kernfusion da geht's aber auch um
zukünftige Generationen von Reaktoren
und es ist natürlich ein riesigen
Unterschied ob sie
was sind denn den Abfall haben über
hunderttausende von Jahren wo keiner die
Lagerung bei sich in der Nähe haben will
oder ob sie darüber reden dass
wesentlich weniger gefährlicher Abfall
in 300 Jahren nicht mehr da ist kein
klares oh wir sollten die hätten die mal
lieber weiter betrieben die AKWs ich
höre aber auch kein klares das war eine
Fehler damals unter merke also die
klaren Antworten die sind sie glaube ich
ein Titel wunderschön
es war damals die richtige Entscheidung
aus der Kernenergie auszusteigen es ist
falsch zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
auszusteigen wir haben gesagt dass man
mindestens bis 2024 die Reaktoren
weiterlaufen lassen müsste wir haben
gesagt dass wir zusätzliche neue
Brennstäbe benötigen Markus Söder hat
von vom Ende des Jahrzehnts gesprochen
jedenfalls geht's darum dass in der
jetzigen Situation das nicht geht jetzt
bei der FDP an der Basis
man sprach davon Atombombe ja also Atome
den magischen
Mund genommen aber natürlich er hat
schon recht das ist ja sie haben es das
alles ich kann eigentlich nur das
unterstreichen was ich gesagt habe alles
was ich gesagt haben ist richtig dazu
und ich glaube das Denken auch die
Mehrheit an der Basis in der FDP und das
Denken auch wahrscheinlich die meisten
FDP Wähler ja und natürlich ein Problem
klar in der Koalition muss man
Kompromisse eingehen und man muss halt
immer fairerweise sagen die FDP hat auch
einige schon verhindert jetzt von noch
schlimmeren und jetzt noch mal auf die
CDU zu sprechen kommen wenn ich mir
anschaue da wo sie Koalition machen mit
der SPD nicht schlimm aber
Baden-Württemberg oder jetzt in Berlin
ja mit mir den Grünen ja oder mit der
SPD da ist das Entgegenkommen der CDU
und die die Art wie man eigene Sachen
durchsetzt sehr viel weniger noch als
die FDP das macht also ich bin da
kritisch gegenüber meiner eigenen Partei
sehr kritisch sogar wenn sie halb so
kritisch gegenüber ihrer eigenen Partei
auch werden dann sind wir auf einer Welt
der FDP ab und tritt in der CDU
eigentlich klappt das haben wir hier
haben Sie denn schon eine Wärmepumpe
sind sie da schon komplett drauf
eingerichtet oder rechnen Sie sich schon
mal alles aus also ich wohne ja nicht
hauptsächlich in Deutschland aber ich
habe nur viel Verwandtschaft hier und da
wird ganz genau drauf geschaut also das
ist ein riesen Thema zwischen 10 und 30
50.000 kostet das werden in diesem Jahr
nicht reagiert und eine Höhle oder
muss das nächste Jahr das mit der
Wärmepumpe höchstwahrscheinlich machen
aber was mich an ihrer Ausführungen ein
bisschen so munter gemacht hat war aber
auch dass sie sagten ja wir können das
machen was politisch möglich ist na das
haben wir gesagt im Sinne was was die
Klima Kleber hier tun wir können nur so
weit unsere Klima Politik voranbringen
das das ist in die gesetzlichen Rahmen
hineinpasst aber letztendlich muss ja
etwas getan werden die Frage ist nur wie
schnell soll er sein und wie dramatisch
das aber was alle wissen aber noch nicht
realisiert haben ist es wird Kosten es
wird jeden Geld kosten also ein Stück
von unserem Wohlstand wegnehmen wenn wir
nicht an anderer Stelle effizienter sind
und da versuchen zu kompensieren und
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe sagen sie
ja wir würden das genauso machen was die
Zielrichtung betrifft aber würden sie im
marktwirtschaftlich aufsetzen weil dann
nicht auf obstruiert wird mit welchen
Maßnahmen da gearbeitet wird sondern wir
würden das in der Gesellschaft
überlassen dass sie was findet und dann
würde die effiziente Lösung sicherlich
passieren reicht das aus reicht das
auszusagen
dass es kein Ziel sein kann dass am Ende
Deutschland Arm und die industrialisiert
ist aber sicher Faktenlage für unser
Leben auf dem Planeten nichts verändert
hat Katastrophe
viele Autos viele Autos Zulieferer die
sagen jetzt wir gehen in die USA also
das ist ja kein Horror Gemälde sondern
das passiert schon ja und das wenn die
Politik so weiter betrieben wird da
werden auch immer mehr Unternehmen gehen
also das ist eine ganz reale Gefahr wie
gesagt wir haben die höchsten
Energiepreise in Deutschland weltweit
das ist kein Standort plus sondern ganz
im Gegenteil dazu haben wir sehr sehr
hohe Steuern sehr sehr hohe Bürokratie
also wir haben einiges zum abarbeiten
das auch nicht alles in den letzten
anderthalb Jahren passiert da haben sie
recht aber das sind eine Menge von
Aufgaben die wir zu erledigen haben und
wir machen zurzeit eigentlich nur alles
um es den Menschen schwerer zu machen um
Wirtschaft zu belasten und
Standortbedingungen zu verschlechtern
und das sollten wir uns mal überlegen
wie wir eine Gegenbewegung schwerer zu
machen etwas was sie in ihrem Umfeld
merken dass die Sorge groß ist und das
was da auf Kosten auf einen zukommt am
Ende der Traum vom Häuschen die man sich
ein Leben lang hat er arbeitet hat
plötzlich Arzt und zwar mega Belastung
viele junge Familien auch haben sich
Wohneigentum angeschafft so in den
letzten fünf bis zehn Jahren die Zinsen
haben es hergegeben die Banken waren
großzügig mit dem mit dem Geld so die
ganzen die ganzen jungen Familien die
stehen jetzt wirklich vor der Angst ab
nächsten Jahr vielleicht ihre alte Gasse
Heizung oder eine Ölheizung austauschen
zum Beispiel müssen gegen die Wärmepumpe
die Anschaffung für die Wärmepumpe diese
30 40.000 ist das eine aber genau
richtigerweise schon gesagt ich selber
auch ich mein Haus ist aus den 70er
Jahren ich habe dort keine
Fußbodenheizung verbaut das heißt das
eine Wärmepumpe macht für mich im Moment
überhaupt gar keinen Sinn das heißt ich
kann richtig Geld in die Hand nehmen und
das Haus umbauen damit eine Wärmepumpe
auch im übrigen effizient effizient
arbeitet und das glaube ich das glaube
ich ist auch das große Problem was in
der Bevölkerung momentan
ausgerechnet haben Sie irgendeine
Hausnummer 80 und 100.000 €, was ich
investieren musste in meinem Haus um das
jetzt letztendlich ja und das und das
kann sich eine junge Familie die vor
fünf Jahren eine Finanzierung auf 10
Jahre gemacht Monat schlichtweg nicht
leisten so ich glaube das ist auch wie
bei allen politischen Fragen immer eine
Frage davon wie versteht die Bevölkerung
denn die Politik ich glaube wir sind uns
alle einig darüber dass wir uns besser
von russischem Gas oder russischem
ölabhängig machen ich das das versteht
jeder da muss nur meine Alternative
geboten werden was macht denn die
Bundesregierung derzeit die haut rein
und sagt so ab 24 ist Schluss mit
fossilen Brennstoffen ihr müsst euch
alle umrüsten aber eine Alternative wird
nicht geboten die Alternative die die
geboten wird ist elektrische Energie
jetzt stellen wir uns mal alle die Frage
was passiert denn wenn ganz Deutschland
eine Wärmepumpe betreibt die um die
16.000 Kilowattstunden Strom im Jahr
braucht in in Spitzenzeiten auch
ordentlich belassen so dann tanken wir
alle noch unsere Autos voll und uns zu
guter Letzt zu guter Letzt fahren wir
dann mit der Bahn die auch elektrisch
betrieben ist logischerweise aber ein
Film der früher mal 2000 Watt hatte
jetzt nur noch 900 haben darf weil die
europäische unionsvorschreibt also um
2000 Watt
kein Mensch und da müssen Alternativen
geboten werden man muss erlangen
langfristig ran an die Ziele man muss
sagen wir setzen uns zum Ziel
auszusteigen und wir bieten euch
folgende Alternative mit dem Ergebnis
dass die Nutzung nicht teurer wird als
jetzt und das fehlt völlig und deshalb
bin ich mir ziemlich sicher dass das da
noch ordentlich Ärger geben wird und ich
glaube das ist ein Thema das wird uns
noch lange beschäftigen so wie Sie
sicherlich auch unsere Zuschauer und
Zuschauer ganz kurze Pause gleich sind
wir zurück hier bei 8:15 Uhr wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie